I do like my friends
this beautiful family stop me
[Music]
I love you too I love you man this is a
story about Saudi people not Saudi
politics out on the rooftop of what
seems like the rooftop of the world here
high high high up in the Saudi mountains
today we got another adventure first
stop will be a Wadi and then to some
amazing mountain destination and all the
adventures along the way right brother
[Laughter]
[Music]
I've just burned my hands on some hot
water I'll show you what a pharmacy is
like here
so long it's okay
video Jimmy oh okay shook it up you
cannot I burn with water
Shh you have something okay peek at him
cream good yeah yeah yeah it's a very
nice story you have man beautiful shoe
Corrado nice aroma
nice guy so well some of these you know
some of the streets can look a little
chaotic the insides of some of these
buildings are absolutely beautiful like
it's a pharmacy out of any any big city
in the world really I was told the
locals here shook watt which is very
stimulating substance it's like a leaf
that you chew on it's very popular in
Yemeni culture and since Yemeni culture
really bleeds over into this region it's
very popular here and it's legal here
the rest of Saudi it's not legal but
this region I guess it's probably like
prohibition like there's no way you're
gonna remove that stuff so they just let
it let it go
76 km/h and 49 minutes and it's only
because it's super everything's super
windy here this place is a graveyard of
vehicles there's just nowhere to put
them
there's no flat space though the only
flat spaces on this road
[Music]
Saudi Arabia has that feel it has that
feel of sending I'm on the outside
obviously I can't I can't get it but it
feels like yeah a lot of things are
nailed down very tightly you don't have
to agree with the country's politics to
travel to it and to connect with the
people it's a little bit juvenile
actually I'm gonna say it's a bit
juvenile to associate someone that grew
up in a system and just label them
that's easy cheap label you know someone
in 18 year old Saudi who lives in a
under government you don't like for
example like is that any of their phone
is that is that how they need to be
labeled do I need to be labeled through
my politics I really don't want to be my
country's politics I'm not happy with
the administration right now it's not
someone that values like I share common
values with so if I don't want that why
would I go into the world and act like
that and I think
for those that maybe haven't traveled
much this might be a harder concept to
grasp but really people are not politics
every bit of content on the Internet has
an agenda there's no exception to that
my agenda is straight office I saw a lot
of the world I was told all these places
were dangerous I had a different
experience and I want to show that to
people if you aren't going to travel to
these parts of the world but I show
another narrative other than the
fear-based Nightly News narrative
yes it's not even nightly use anymore
24-hour days I'm just gonna show you
what I see you can take it for what it
is your honor
didn't expect this though
who did really come on I bet 99% of you
did not expect to see this in Saudi
Arabia
[Music]
[Music]
every one of them
guys there were some [ __ ] back there at
this intersection I couldn't fill me if
I felt that what a crashed
but it was a roundabout and one guy guys
starts going the other way of the
roundabout and see if two like
it's impossible to explain because it's
tumbling
just what across the valley now going up
to cellar mountainside and it's starting
to get very beautiful again
[Music]
the spark is having trouble getting up
this hill no joke we're doing 15k
[Music]
all these people all these locals just
stopped by because I'm on the side of
the road asking if they can help me if I
broke down or whatever and then I heard
the prayer I don't know how it's
possible I mean there's nothing around
as far as people but I heard the call to
prayer why don't you sweat above above
the car down on it what a surreal place
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
Salaam wha dealer job
yeah brother
we're holding hands and he's got a
dagger that's cool man
okay see it not my feet Mafi it okay
okay on the way down to the water
why do you lose Jim idealism [ __ ] why
do you like your logic these guys came
out from I do love you too brother lb lb
I love you crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look around you these rocks guys so
interesting these lines in different
colors are in the boulders it's
absolutely massive I can't explain it I
don't think the cameras gonna capture it
at all but I've been to Zion Utah I've
been to the Grand Canyon
I've never seen a like sheer cliff drop
like that Wow look at this water
[Applause]
it's a new light only coming to places
like this if you just keep it open and
just go with
[Music]
that walk is just hanging over like it
wants to fall at any time just like all
these other rocks actually cold this
water must be 18
60-66 something like that backing up the
trail this beautiful family stop me gave
me a Snickers
KitKat what is this put hopes hogs in
some soup
without him
good
welcome to dia thank you wow what a
place oh my god the hospitality here is
amazing people really the people really
care they really do go out of their way
to help how about this for unbelievable
scenery
this root structure symbolizes what
Saudi Arabia is it's complicated super
complicated and beautiful I thought I
had an understanding of what Saudi
Arabia would be before hand a little bit
right and no like I was completely off
[Applause]
such old trees in here
and we have something that looks like
out of Southeast Asia palms
some other decision which trees I don't
know what they are
thank you very much thank you brother
thank you brother
I love you too I love you man yeah this
shot really puts it into perspective the
roller skate next to rock
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I stopped over there walk to get a
picture of the video and these very kind
people invited me elected my friends
yeah this is how easy it is to travel
now we just translate to go five me
this is cop sir MRSA okay this is the I
think the traditional saw do ya cheese
on way down there at the red see way
down there and up here the fog comes in
- very cool no no I quit now brother
dude this this will give me children oh
it makes me very strong okay finally got
my traditional Saudi meal finally got my
cop sir I don't know what else you can
ask for in a day of traveling radical
extreme landscapes people giving food
tea welcoming me and a guy saying I love
you actually if you guys saying I love
you I mean what else do you want in a
day of travel it's completely not what I
thought it would be